- I don't feel guilty
about my coffee.
I don't feel guilty.
It's the same thing I was
saying the other day about,
you know, I could for
the cup of coffee a day,
all the things you could do.
And I'm like, I look forward
to that coffee so much.
- Mmm-hmm.
- I don't care that
it's a waste of money.
I don't care that I
give Starbucks $4.87
at least twice a day for a drink
that costs them less than
seven cents to make. (laughing)
And creates garbage
for the world.
I mean, everything about
it is just disgusting
and I really loath myself
when I throw that empty cup
in the trash.
But when I get that cup,
it's like I get a high.
I get so excited,
it's worth it to me.
- But that's why you look
what's worth it to you.
(rock music)
- What did you learn in your
research for this book that,
what's like a nugget that
maybe I can take into my life
and our listeners
can take into theirs?
Just some money advice, that's
simple and not overwhelming.
- Well, ah, this is gonna
be slightly overwhelming.
- Okay.
That's not what I asked for,
and it's not what
I paid you for.
- Yeah, sorry.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I only came on here cause I'm
being financially blackmailed.
(laughing)
Oh god!
So yeah,
so what I did when
I was starting, was,
and I know you just said
you don't look at anything,
so I'm really sorry
to stress you out.
- I don't.
- I printed out my bank
statements for the whole year.
Printed 'em out.
And then, cause
they do it by month,
and then I went through
them with a highlighter
and I highlighted stuff
that seemed insane to me.
So I would be like,
well that's very high.
Or I would be like,
wait a minute,
why is my car payment so much?
Or why is, you know,
this kinda thing.
I realized I had two
subscriptions to something,
and I was like, well I
don't need two of those.
- Right.
- So I drop one.
One thing I noticed was
I was paying a lot
for parking, in LA.
And I was like, do I really?
I would run into a store for
15 minutes, pay for four hours.
It's like, no, don't do that.
So I went through and then
I made a list of what,
and I hate this
sort of generalized
information that's like,
don't buy a latte,
don't buy avocado toast,
because that doesn't
apply to everyone.
So I was like, you
can have a latte,
but go through your
bank statements
and notice what is too
much for you, personally.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'll buy coffee
every day and/or make,
You know, coffee's
important to me.
But I'm gonna,
But I was like, parking is not
necessary in this situation.
Or like, drive around
for another second,
and look for an open spot.
Or like,
you know, oh well I
looked and was like,
oh my god, my car
insurance is so high.
So then I left
that car insurance
and looked for a better deal.
Just things where I wouldn't
have ever looked at it.
- Just seeing it in front of you
I know.
- There was one month, I
talk about in the book,
where I bought $600
worth of stuff on Amazon.
What?!
What was that, why?
- Yeah.
- So I went through
and was like, oh Jesus,
I didn't need this, I didn't
need this, I didn't need this.
And I was like, okay, I was,
whatever I was
uncomfortable with,
I could see it in front of me.
- I know, that's a good point.
Your spending is certainly,
- It's horrible.
- based on your mood
and your thoughts and,
The other day I went shopping
and I bought like one shirt
and my mood was
instantly elevated.
The person I was with was like,
what just happened to you?
And I was like, I
bought something.
- Mmm-hmm.
- And I'm trying to,
you know, do Marie Kondo
and get crap out of my life
and not have any more things.
But it truly is like,
buying things makes you
feel good sometimes.
- Yeah.
- I'm trying to get
it out of my system.
You said something about
the coffees, I get,
I spend $16 on coffee
a day, everyday.
- Is that for four cups?
_ I don't care.
Yeah.
- Right.
- It's like three.
It's like maybe two
or three Starbucks,
at least two, everyday.
- But if you're okay
with that, then whatever.
- I'm so, it brings me joy.
- Right.
- And you know what, Gaby?
I often say to myself,
what if I die tomorrow?
Like what are we saving for?
- Yeeah.
- I don't think the world
is going that great,
and I don't trust
that even my money
is gonna be in the
banks when I want it,
so I'm kind of like,
let me just spend it up.
- Oh you're me--
- There's a part of me
that vacillates between
spend it all, or save it all,
and so I can pay for my,
- You're me in season one.
- Really?
- Yeah, that's what
I came into it with.
- God.
- And my dad, my
parents are like,
can't take it with you, man,
cause they're like
baby boomer, hippies.
- That's what my dad says.
- Yeah.
- And then the next
day it'll be like,
well we are broke, Nikki,
and I'm just like,
- Yes.
- Pick a lane, mom and dad.
What are we?
- My mom says often, oh, well
you're our retirement plan.
- Yeah.
- Which is a nightmare.
- Oh I say that to my
parents all the time,
and I hold it over their head.
It's kinda nice to be,
like I'm making enough money
now that I feel like have,
I'm buying my, I often,
oh this sounds so bad.
- What?
- But the fact that I
can help my parents out
if they're in a financial
situation right now,
feels so good to me.
- Yeah.
- And not because they're
gonna be happy and secure,
but like, I told you.
- Yes!
Yes!
I feel that too.
- That's not nice.
- I told you so.
And then I'm the parent.
- Oh you wanted me
to be a teacher?
Did ya?
- Mm-hmm.
- Is that what you, that was
your big sight for me, mom?
Was to be an English professor?
Well guess who wouldn't
be going out to,
not that mom demands
these things from me,
and wants me to buy her stuff.
My mom would be happy shopping
and eating at Goodwill
the rest of her life.
Yes I said eating.
(laughing)
But,
I do feel,
I feel great, being able to,
to, being rich.
- Yes.
- And being able to buy
things for the people I love.
- Yes.
- So that they, so I
can buy their love.
- Yeah, I mean, yes.
Well I did a book tour
for the first book.
And we weren't going to South
Florida where my parents are.
So I flew them to the
Boston and New York events.
And put them up in a hotel.
And they, when they got
there, they were like,
it's so nice that your
publisher did this.
And I was like, I did this!
I did this!
And they were like, oh
my god, you did this?
- So nice.
- And I was like, yes!
Yes I fucking did!
And they were like, I
mean I think they are,
not slightly uncomfortable,
but they kinda,
I think they've lost the power.
- Yeah.
- So, then when I went
home for Thanksgiving,
I was like I'm
staying in an Airbnb.
And they were like, wait what?
And I was like, I will be by
the beach, if you need me.
But I am not staying
in the house.
And they were upset.
- I think that is such,
that is what my
therapist taught me
is one of the greatest
boundaries you can have
is not staying at home
with your parents,
- Yes.
- When you go home.
It's such a power move
- Because it's a cluster fuck.
- And it protects
you from so much.
They're gonna take
offense to it.
But in the end,
it really protect,
and I don't do it, I stay
at home with my parents.
And I do the opposite of like,
yeah my room's trash
but guess what?
I pay for everything
when I'm home.
- Yes.
- And we eat out constantly.
You eat out more in one week,
then you do in a whole
year when I'm home.
So my room's gonna be a mess
and you're not gonna say
anything about it to me, Mom.
It's like you're buying,
- Freedom, it's freedom.
- You're buying freedom.
And it's,
- It's complete freedom.
- And I always
question if I was,
because I have been
broke and relied on them,
and it wasn't good
for our relationship.
Not that this is even good
for our relationship either.
Me feeling like I have
some sort of upper hand,
because I'm paying for things.
Cause they're not
even asking for it.
But it just, I don't
know what my point is.
My point is,
- No I mean, I
think I would have,
They're a lot, my parents.
And I think I would
have been very,
I think it would have damaged
our relationship further,
for me to stay in the house.
And so, and then
they were upset,
and they have no boundaries.
Them and my sister
have no boundaries.
It's like very weird what
they talk about and are,
and I kinda have pulled back.
And then the family
narrative is, Gaby's a bitch.
But so, I like,
But I was like, this
is the craziest,
is I said, they were upset that
I was staying at the Airbnb
and I said, well that's fine,
I'm, you know, gonna be in
your city, in an Airbnb,
if you wanna see me,
I'm so happy to spend
every second with you.
- Wow.
- If you don't wanna see
me, I'll have a vacation.
They lost it.
And then I was like,
this is the healthiest
boundary, one.
And two, I realized that
they want to see you
more than you want to see them.
- Yes.
- So you have the
power (laughs).
- It's really good
that you did that
and not a lot of people do that.
And if you're listening at home
and you just got done with
the holidays and you're like,
I could never do
that, yes you could.
- Yes.
- You don't have to go home
and stay with your family,
when you are going
home for the holidays.
- If you have money, yes.
- You can get a hotel.
Yes, of course.
But you could even
stay with a friend.
- Yes.
- You don't have to
go back home.
There's nothing,
there's no contract.
We all just assume,
we all just blindly go,
yeah I'm gonna stay in
my old childhood bedroom.
None of that has
to happen, and yes,
they will be disappointed,
and they'll be like,
what does this mean?
It doesn't,
- Then use my line.
Say, I'll be in your same city.
I'm happy to spend as much
time with you as you'd like.
If you're that upset with me
and you don't want to see me,
I understand and I'll
hang out with my friends.
- It's a good line.
- Ughhh.
- I don't know
how to do, I mean,
I did it one time.
I went back and got a hotel.
And I never did it again,
cause I'm always like,
I just wanna save the
money and stay at home.
But I think you're right,
in the end it's
just better to have,
- It's so guilty.
- those boundaries.
- That's why you look at
what's worth it to you.
- Yeah.
- And then if having, you know,
two Dropbox accounts, which
I did, and I was like,
why don't I just
use Google Drive?
- Okay.
- And you get rid of 'em.
And then that's the equivalent,
that's like a 9.99
payment a month.
- Yeah, I don't have, I will
never have expensive handbags,
cause most of them
- Right!
- are made of leather
and I don't believe
in leather goods.
- Right, it doesn't matter.
- But also because
I've never cared about leather,
I've never cared about
handbags, I've just never.
And I want to.
I wanna be a girl who
cares about nice things.
But my bag is always a
tote, a disgusting tote.
(laughing)
A disgusting tote that you get
- Right you just look at--
in a gift bag.
- That's why a lot of money
advice is too generalized.
You wanna look at
what matters to you.
- Okay.
- And what matters to
each person is different.
- So the coffee a day thing,
don't have shame
about the things
that actually really
matter to you,
that you're spending money on.
- And,
- That's just.
- A lot of the shaming stuff
is specifically towards women.
They'll be like,
don't get a manicure.
Don't get your hair dyed.
And it's like, oh I'm sorry,
are you gonna tell dudes
not to buy sneakers?
Like do you know what I mean?
It's all directed at women.
- I want to not get my hair
done, or nails done, ever again.
I'm so tired of it,
and I resent men that they
don't have to do it, Gaby.
- They don't have to do it.
It's that picture of
Beyonce, very dressed up,
and Ed Sheeran wearing jeans.
- I've never loved anything
more than that picture.
(laughing)
(rock music)